first of all thank you we want to
introduce all of you to our friend alex
alex is a person and a thing and one of
the questions we wanted to answer what
how can we advise Alex so that he or she
is aware of his or her life choices and
part of us introducing you to alex is
explaining a little bit about who alex
is alex is a low-income minority student
he's in the tent he or she is in the
10th grade and they're a good student
but most importantly he or she is not
aware of the vast array of resources
available to them so alex is confused
you know he or she is interested in a
lot of different topics but doesn't
really know where to go the counselor at
the school is a little bit overtaxed
there's 1200 students in the high school
and doesn't really have time to sit down
and do career counseling with them the
teachers overwhelms because there's 30
kids in the classroom and they have to
try to you know also grade and spend a
lot of time doing things related to the
curriculum but Alex wants to explore his
or her life opportunities so we wanted
Alex to meet Alex and Alex is an
innovative online low-cost platform that
connects students that don't know what
choices they have to professionals in
the community peers researchers
professors who can talk to them a little
bit more about what opportunities are
available to them so it's really
important for them to connect with these
people so Alex creates an online profile
and can interact with all of these
different stakeholders who are
interested in Alex you know knowing what
kind of choices he or she has as far as
career or college opportunities and we
want to emphasize the the college and
career readiness because college maybe
for some students maybe not for others
though
well you already have a website in
Portuguese I'm sorry so sweet husband
boss how does one thought well because
we're going to be once we launch it you
know we're hoping to sustain the
platform mainly online because we know
that you know for substance it's hard
for them to physically get to people so
if you're in a neighborhood maybe your
family doesn't have a car you're able to
go online at any point maybe live chat
with your online mentor get advice from
them video chat with them or talk with
them on the phone and we would like to
be able to set up opportunities for
there to be that human to human
interaction as well but in the case that
students aren't able to do that you know
they're able to hopefully you know get
an internet connection either at school
or at home that allows them to interact
with the people that can expose them to
some of their life options you guys
connected with career village or path
source or any of the other solutions of
this sort that are out there we have not
but we think that this would be a great
addition to the menu of options that are
out there and possibly lend support and
maybe target specific you know groups of
students that we feel need the
additional support and additional
resources
in the third is there a way to sort of
help scale it you know beyond like
one-to-one or yeah well it's how I come
in alguns the everyman so Alex isn't
just once unit we hope to start at a
school actually and see it you know
maybe over a two-year period or so let's
always started with the 10th grade and
just see over two years or so you know
is this something that's actually
scalable and possibly expand it to other
schools that have a similar interest in
seeing students connect with
professionals but who maybe don't have
those in school resources to do that